derrière ces grilles la place Rouge se
prépare au festivités détente une scène
pour accueillir un concert Vladimir
Poutine en personne pourrait même faire
une apparition une cérémonie pour
marquer l'annexion des quatre régions
ukrainiennes placardées partout Donetsk
louansk Herson zapporja Russie suivi
d'un point d'exclamation
demain au Palais du Grand Kremlin dans
la salle Saint-Georges à 15h aura lieu
la cérémonie de signatures des accords
sur l'adhésion des nouveaux territoires
à la Fédération de Russie le président
Poutine prononcera un discours important
lors de cet événement
une cérémonie qui en rappelle une autre
souvenez-vous c'était le 18 mars 2014
Vladimir Poutine déclarait alors que la
Crimée péninsule du sud de l'Ukraine
était riche
[Musique]
ce vendredi il faut s'attendre au même
scénario à la même ferveur d'ailleurs
les responsables installés par Moscou
dans les régions prochainement annexées
sont déjà arrivés sur place
nous félicitons tous les Russes du monde
entier pour cette grande fête nous
l'avons fait moi les régions de Herson
zapporigiak feront désormais partie de
la Russie pour toujours
déroulées dans la douleur la guerre fait
rage depuis plus de 7 mois et
aujourd'hui aucun des quatre blastes
n’est entièrement aux mains des Russes
restent donc à connaître les frontières
de ces régions annexées pour l'instant
le Kremlin joue l'ambiguïté
des annexions qui font aussi suite à des
référendums imposés et qui pourraient
marquer un tournant dans la guerre car
les attaques de Kiev seront alors
perçues par Moscou comme des agressions
et Vladimir Poutine a déjà prévenu il
est prêt à utiliser tous les moyens de
son arsenal pour défendre son territoire